In this place, we reported a new type of microalgae
that grew only on top of the spiderwebs that covered the cave entrance.
Have you ever seen a spiderweb early in the morning?
It's covered with dew,
so this microalgae learned that in order to carry photosynthesis
in the coast of the driest desert on Earth,
they could use the spiderwebs.
So here they may access the water from the fogs
that regularly cover these areas in the morning.
In another cave, we found a different type of microalgae.
This one is able to use ocean mist as a source of water,
and strikingly lives in the very bottom of a cave,
so it has adapted to live with less than 0.1 percent
of the amount of light that regular plants need.
These type of findings suggest to me that on Mars,
we may find even photosynthetic life inside caves.
And by the way, that's me.
(Laughter)
Now, for almost 15 years this region of Yungay, discovered by NASA,
was thought to be the driest place of this desert,
but I knew that it was not.
How? You already know the answer.
Because I was born and raised in this desert.
So I remembered that I usually see fogs in Yungay,
so after setting sensors in a number of places,
where I remember never seeing fogs or clouds,
I reported four other sites much drier than Yungay,
with this one, María Elena South,
being the truly driest place on Earth,
as dry as Mars,
and amazingly, just a 15-minute ride
from the small mining town where I was born.
Now, in this search, we were trying to actually find the dry limit
for life on Earth,
a place so dry that nothing was able to survive in it.
But even here, well hidden underground,
we found a number of different microorganisms,
which suggested to me that similarly dry places, like Mars,
may be inhabited.
We even have some preliminary evidences
that these microorganisms may still be active
in the desiccated state,
like walking mummies all around us,
and that they may be using UV radiation as a source of energy.
If confirmed, this would have a huge impact on our definition of life,
on how we look for life elsewhere in the universe.
Due to its clear skies, by 2020,
60 percent of the biggest telescopes on Earth
will be located in the Atacama,
and while everyone else will be looking among the stars
to answer the question, "Are we alone?"
I will be looking down to the ground
searching for this same answer
in my own backyard.
Thank you.
(Applause)